[Música]
en 1990 el gobierno de italia contrató a
los mejores ingenieros para que
empezaran la famosa torre inclinada de
pisa hubo numerosos intentos de
enderezar la torre en sus 800 años de
existencia pero los modelos digitales de
este equipo revelaron la urgencia de la
situación pero decían que la torre se
caería si alcanzaba un ángulo de 5,44
grados se encontraba en ese momento a
5,5 grados nadie entendía como la torre
aún se sostenía pero la crisis era
evidente debían resolver un problema que
había pasmado a los ingenieros durante
siglos y debían hacerlo con rapidez para
comprender esta situación es necesario
entender por qué la torre se inclinó en
primer lugar en el siglo 12 la república
marítima y acaudalada de pizza se
dispuso a convertir sus catedrales en
obras magníficas
los obreros embellecieron y expandieron
las iglesias existentes y agregaron un
enorme baptisterio con domo a la plaza
en 1.173 comenzó la construcción de un
campanil o campanario
los ingenieros y arquitectos de la época
eran expertos en sus oficios pero a
pesar de todo su conocimiento en
ingeniería sabían poco sobre el suelo en
que se sostenía la torre el nombre pizza
proviene de una palabra griega que
significa suelo pantanoso lo que
describe a la perfección la arcilla el
lodo y la arena húmeda bajo la
superficie de la ciudad los romanos en
la antigüedad contrarrestaban
condiciones similares con enormes
pilares de piedra llamados pilotes que
se enterraban en la estable base rocosa
de la tierra sin embargo los arquitectos
de la torre pensaron que unos cimientos
de tres metros serían suficientes para
sostener la estructura que era
relativamente baja
desafortunadamente para ellos unos
cuatro años más tarde el lado sur de la
torre estaba ya bajo tierra hacer
cambios en los cimientos hubiese sido
normalmente un error fatal si se
agregaba más peso la presión de los
pisos superiores hundiría la estructura
y aumentaría la inclinación de forma
peligrosa pero la construcción se detuvo
en el piso cuarto por casi un siglo pues
pizza se sumió en una prolongada guerra
está extendida pausa permitió que el
suelo se asentará y cuando la
construcción se reanudó en el año 1200
72 los cimientos descansaban sobre el
suelo un poco más estable bajo la
dirección del arquitecto giovanni y
simone los obreros compensaron la leve
inclinación de la torre por medio de
pisos más altos sobre el lado sur
pero el peso de la construcción extra
hizo que ese lado se hundiera más aún
cuando completaron el piso séptimo y el
campanario el ángulo de inclinación era
de 16 grados
durante siglos los ingenieros
implementaron varias estrategias para
solucionar esto en 1838 cavaron un
pasadizo alrededor de la base para
examinar los cimientos hundidos pero al
remover la arena de apoyo solamente
empeoró la inclinación en 1935 el cuerpo
italiano de ingenieros inyectó argamasa
en la base para fortalecerla sin embargo
no fue distribuida uniformemente por los
cimientos y esto provocó otra
inclinación repentina todos estos
intentos fallidos sumados a los
cimientos inestables hicieron que la
torre se acercará cada es más a su
límite y sin el conocimiento definitivo
sobre la composición del suelo los
ingenieros lo podían localizar el ángulo
fatal de la torre ni idear un
dispositivo que evitara su caída tras la
segunda guerra mundial los
investigadores idearon pruebas para
identificar esas variables desconocidas
en 1970 los ingenieros calcularon el
centro de gravedad de la torre contando
con esta información y con nueva
capacidad de cómputo los ingenieros
pudieron determinar la dureza del suelo
la trayectoria de la torre y cuánto
debían excavar exactamente para que la
torre se mantuviera de pie en 1992 el
equipo excavó túneles diagonales para
extraer 38 metros cúbicos de tierra de
abajo de la torre en el lado norte luego
colocaron un contrapeso temporal de 600
toneladas de lingotes de plomo por
ultimo anclaron la base con cables de
acero más de seis siglos posteriores a
su construcción la torre fue finalmente
enderezada a un ángulo de unos cuatro
grados nadie quería que la torre cayera
pero tampoco querían perder la atracción
más famosa de la zona
actualmente la torre tiene unos 55 o 56
metros de altura seguramente continuará
estable por al menos 300 años como
monumento a la belleza de la
imperfección
[Música]
si desea continuar aprendiendo
suscríbase a nuestro canal tenga
curiosidad manténgase conectado
[Música]
ah